what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here and it's John Humphrey here oh look
at this it's kind of a cinematic
crossover now that John took over the
channel for a week that's right I'm
putting together a special team yeah
just you and me to watch Game of Thrones
so I managed to avoid the internet for a
while so Game of Thrones the I heard one
thing I did off of a video that was not
even Game of Thrones related right Lloyd
everything apparently a whole week I
managed to avoid nothing when the
episode got leaked in Spain and then an
air here in America oh dude I hit the
circuit breaker shut off your power you
know don't get newspaper the day I
decide I didn't even go on like Yahoo
calm like I've avoided everything yeah
you cannot just touch the outside world
you're Amish until you've seen Game of
Thrones right before filming I'm looking
at comments on a Thor video this is one
thing so but and you know I don't want
to [ __ ] or reaction for you guys so
when it happens I'm sure I'll be
affected yeah but I won't be as
surprised anyway yeah so after we could
only show ten minutes of this for you
guys
who's standing in Winterfell again
because of me you didn't win it back
John didn't win it back he lost the
Battle of the bastards the Knights of
the Vale won the battle and they wrote
not for me or you Ross we're traveling
the world and training dream will you
betray me I suffer things you can never
imagine
that is absolutely terrifying
whoa
[Music]
flame on
[Music]
set up on the vibrating but
like fireman
[Music]
[Music]
on hound oh come on dude
[Music]
[Applause]
take one
Haywood they got one
don't break it man don't break it
[Music]
whatever except I'll say distant
rumbling use a budget
Oh
Oh
King Arthur
oh [ __ ] they're gonna get across awkward
they're gonna break the honor to King
Arthur this [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
oh they're gonna kick our to finish it
what a mess get up don't be the one guy
oh come on dude
oh [ __ ] they can walk on it no dude no
[Music]
oh the hound done [ __ ] up oh yeah you
got the dagger for Sam that's how the
dagger got
[Music]
oh man he's gonna be there like one
piece
[Music]
[Music]
well I'm Daenerys they get over there
[Music]